[Musica]
l'onda è una sinusoide a un picco
massimo è uno minimo un altro un basso
un andamento regolare
siamo circondati da onde sinusoidali
nella nostra vita anche qui in questa
sala onde radio luce microonde raggi ics
raggi gamma
quando parliamo di onde inevitabile
pensare al mare perché la singola
molecola d'acqua sale e scende da un
livello medio per seguire l'andamento
sinusoidale di ogni onda sul suo cammino
c'è poco da fare la sinusoide esprime un
senso di sicurezza di tranquillità di
regolarità
proprio come il mare quando albo ma
attenzione non sempre è così a volte
succede che il mare si ritiri le onde si
allontanano dalla riva e noi pensiamo ma
è meglio avremmo una spiaggia è più
grande
eppure la realtà ci appare nella sua
drammaticità
all'orizzonte compare un'onda e diventa
sempre più grande e si avvicina alla
riva e travolge tutto ma era lo stesso
mare tranquillo regolare sinusoidale di
poco fa cosa è successo
e accaduto un evento singolare una
singolarità a partire da quelle onde
lente e apparentemente irrilevanti
quello che è successo e che si è passati
da una funzione costa regolare azione
esponenziale la funzione esponenziale
all'inizio cresce molto lentamente quasi
impercettibilmente ma da un certo punto
in poi cresce molto rapidamente tanto
rapidamente da tendere verso l'infinito
e quando il valore numerico della
funzione esponenziale tende all'infinito
parliamo di singolarità cerco di
raccontarvelo con una leggenda si
racconta che l'imperatore della cina
volesse premiare l'inventore degli
scacchi o imperatore dammi un chicco di
riso per la prima casella 2 per la
seconda 4 per la terza e così via fino a
ricoprire la scacchiera
doppiando ad ogni salto il numero di
chicchi di riso della casella precedente
l'imperatore acconsentì perché
all'inizio il premio sembrava arrivati
all'undicesima casella l'imperatore si
può che neanche in un millennio avrebbe
potuto onorare la sua promessa perché il
chicco di il numero di ricchi di risio
di riso era aumentato esponenzialmente e
anche il genere umano si è voluto a
partire da 64 caselle da un numero
finito da quei soli 5.000 antenati da
cui discendiamo secondo la scienza e
come l'esponenziale anche noi tendiamo
verso l'infinito grazie a degli tsunami
esponenziali a delle onde hanno attivate
dalla tecnologia ad esempio il controllo
del fuoco
l'agricoltura l'invenzione dei decimali
certo se i primi uomini tra quei
cinquemila antenati che hanno dovuto
macinare chilometri per trovare un
partner oggi sapessero che ci basta uno
swipe a destra seduti dal divano
scherzi a parte è innegabile che una
delle principali sfide del genere umano
sia quella di vivere meglio
e infatti siamo l'unico l'unica specie
che ha sempre cercato di estendere il
proprio ambito di applicazione oltre i
limiti di cervelli e corpi biologici
dalla pergamena al download dalle stelle
al gps oggi robot dall'animo gentile
possono aiutarci nella vita di tutti i
giorni
ridurre il numero di morti e feriti per
incidenti stradali è una grande priorità
vogliamo tutti vivere più a lungo e più
in salute e soprattutto vogliamo perdere
meno tempo in casa con le faccende
domestiche
abbiamo capito quindi che per vincere
quella sfida per migliorare la nostra
vita dobbiamo migliorare le macchine che
ci circondano
cioè i computer ma come si migliora un
computer lo si dota di intelligenza che
altro non è che la somma di tre abilità
processare sempre più dati sempre più
velocemente comprendere significati
contesti interazioni nel mondo che ci
circonda e migliorare nel tempo il modo
in cui apprende in una parola
l'intelligenza
artificiale ed ecco che se il dio dei
soldati e un prode guerriero è il dio
dei poveri e un padre generoso
il paradosso è che oggi anche scienziati
creeranno la propria divinità che è una
macchina dall'intelligenza suprema
creata e forgiata dalle loro mani a
nostra immagine e somiglianza e questa è
la svolta simulare nei computer il
funzionamento dei nostri neuroni e
infatti negli anni 90 le reti neurali
erano la grande promessa ma perso lo
subito di interesse perché la tecnologia
dei circuiti integrati non permetteva di
realizzare reti neurali troppo complesse
ma qui la miopia evidente perché abbiamo
imparato che la fase iniziale di una
funzione esponenziale e calma apparente
gli scettici non hanno tenuto conto
della legge di moore
secondo cui il microprocessore cioè il
cuore di un computer aumenta di potenza
raddoppia la sua potenza ogni 18 mesi e
oggi infatti abbiamo algoritmi sempre
più sofisticati ottimizzati hardware
progettato ad hoc per simulare il
funzionamento dei neuroni e sistemi di
feedback che migliorano in maniera
ricorsiva il codice di programmazione
siamo arrivati oggi al di planning
quindi e l'apprendimento profondo da
parte delle macchine quello che sto
dicendo è che abbiamo tra le mani un set
di tecnologie che ci permettono di
prevedere di non essere così tanto
lontani dal momento della singolarità
ma nel concreto cos'è questa singolarità
secondo ray kurzweil e quel momento nel
futuro in cui il progresso tecnologico
accelera ben oltre le nostre capacità di
comprensione e previsione e quel momento
in cui ci rendiamo conto che davanti non
abbiamo la spiaggia più grande ma uno
tsunami in arrivo e la natura di questo
momento è tale per cui le competenze le
capacità umane si fonderanno e si
confonderanno a quelle delle macchine e
infatti la l'intelligenza artificiale
essendo
legata alla legge di moore e quindi allo
sviluppo di circuiti integrati
raddoppierà la sua potenza in maniera
esponenziale e il genere umano si
troverà ad avere a che fare con delle
macchine della complessità e della
potenza di calcolo pari e poi superiore
a quella del cervello umano
questo è l'onda tipica della scienza
quella teorizzata nel modello dei
paradigmi nikon secondo cui la scienza
non avanza per stratificazioni
successive di nuove idee ma avanza per
paradigmi esplosivi esponenziale
rivoluzionari dei nuovi modi di pensare
la singolarità è un'utopia e una
distopia non si sa ancora la risposta di
sicuro ineffabile e imprevedibile è
incomprensibile ci sembra impossibile ma
di sicuro è inevitabile e allora le
domande che ci dobbiamo porre in questo
tempo che abbiamo a disposizione sono
due
quando arriverà la singolarità
tecnologica e vediamo quindi quali sono
le sfide che l'intelligenza artificiale
ha già vinto e quali invece deve ancora
superare rendiamoci conto dello status
quo in primis le macchine devono
migliorare la distinzione tra gli
oggetti è una fragola all edificio
devono migliorare la comprensione dei
contesti perché ci sono una serie di
cadillac infilata nel deserto della
route sics sics devono coprire capire
anche il senso comune come mai ci sono
delle persone in fila e poi c'è quello
che è considerato il vero baluardo
dell'intelligenza artificiale non plus
ultra
l'avete letto e una notizia di qualche
giorno fa lo sapete no creiamo suspense
e ve la dico
pilotare una vita da salerno a positano
quando le macchine riusciranno ad
emulare simulare l'intelligenza degli
autisti saremo molto vicini alla
singolarità tornando seri molto
velocemente invece quali risultati
abbiamo raggiunto in campo medico questo
è il supercomputer watson di ibm che
riesce ad effettuare diagnosi
oncologiche molto precise così come
abbiamo anche altre macchine che possono
anticipare possono prevedere con dieci
anni d'anticipo lo sviluppo
dell'alzheimer
il grado di automazione alla guida
scherzi a parte sta veramente
migliorando tant'è che praticamente ogni
brand automobilistico è coinvolto in un
certo modo in un progetto di
intelligenza artificiale e infatti non
mas che dice che addirittura in futuro
guidare sarà considerata un'attività
illegale
sappiamo benissimo che le macchine
stanno padroneggiando le regole del
gioco imparando a batterci sempre più di
frequente possono produrre comporre
musica classica originale condurre
orchestre addirittura possono replicare
al millimetro la stessa tecnica
pittorica di rembrandt l'esponenziale
esplosivo e nelle esplosioni tempismo è
tutto l'abbiamo visto stamattina se vuoi
cavalcare un'onda il tempo è cruciale
perché se sali troppo presto
probabilmente sarai solo
e i pessimisti spegneranno qualsiasi
entusiasmo il fondo per la ricerca
se provi a salire troppo tardi invece
l'onda è troppo alta e costoso e
difficile salirmi e che è salito anche
un attimo prima di te è sicuramente più
avvantaggiato
come fare a capire quindi quando avviene
questa singolarità per capire se una
tecnologia ha il potenziale di sfociare
in un esponenziale
basta vedere se è collegata ad un altra
tecnologia che è più avanti di lei sulla
curva dell'esponenziale perché quello
che succede è un effetto traino di fatte
l'intelligenza artificiale essendo
collegata come abbiamo visto la legge di
moore si poteva facilmente prevedere un
inizio lento e poi non è speso
un'esplosione repentina e invece dagli
anni 90 ha anche fino a oltre gli anni
2000 è stato un periodo in cui questa
tecnologia è stata ritenuta senza futuro
un periodo chiamato l'inverno
dell'intelligenza artificiale
andiamo alla seconda domanda come
possiamo prepararci a vivere in un mondo
profondamente cambiato dalla tecnologia
avete presente quei gli enigmi quelle
domande quali oggetti porteresti con te
sull'isola deserta la mia personale
risposta
quello che io metterei nello zaino per
il viaggio verso la singolarità sono
etica e competenza
vediamo la prima ci stiamo affacciando
all'epoca gnr ok nanotecnologie robotica
genetica con questo anche praticamente
il microsoft word del dna sempre evitare
il genoma umano è una cosa molto
semplice e che cosa è l'etica se non la
capacità degli scienziati di non peccare
di tracotanza quando mettono le mani sul
dna dell'uomo di non chiedersi solo come
ma soprattutto chi e perché debba
reingegnerizzare l'uomo questa notizia
vera
giuro gli scienziati adesso hanno
trovato il modo per riportare in vita i
dinosauri ma abbiamo cinque film che ci
dicono che non è una idea nel 2029
riusciremo a simulare la il cervello
umano
ok in sotto forma di codice di
programmazione e si stima che entro il
2050 riusciremo a simulare ogni singolo
cervello umano esistente in quel momento
al mondo quando gli scienziati saranno
un milione di volte più intelligenti e
agiranno un milione di volte più
velocemente un'ora sarà come un secolo e
sarà cruciale in quel momento avere un
sistema etico universale e probabile e
con incrollabile e condiviso perché
esisteranno tre tipologie di esseri le
intelligenze artificiali che se ne
andranno in giro per il mondo
ottimizzandolo degli esseri ibridi la
human intelligence cumani con il
cervello connesso alla rete che invece
sono quei problemi che richiedono sia
potenza di calcolo sia tratti umani e
gli esseri umani tradizionali normali
diremo noi che hanno il compito di
presidiare questo sistema etico perché
questi tre esseri non potranno farsi la
guerra ma dovranno collaborare in
maniera positiva e costruttiva
e passiamo alla competenza trump ha
appena perso di attivare la sesta forza
armata degli stati uniti
la space force ci stiamo preparando per
abbandonare questo pianeta la culla
della nostra civiltà
proprio come gli animali abbandonarono
l'acqua per approdare sulla terraferma
ma a loro differenza abbiamo un bagaglio
millenario di competenza che poi la
prospettiva che mi interessa di più per
il ruolo che ho e ninja academy è quello
che succede come dopo l'elettrificazione
della società inizia adesso
il processo di connie ficazione cioè
aggiungiamo via via strati di
intelligenza alle tecnologie esistenti
chi guadagnerà di più in futuro saranno
quelle persone che sapranno lavorare
meglio con le intelligenze artificiali
ora il futuro ci riguarda tutti e il
dovere morale che ha l'intelligenza di
ognuno di voi e di guardare queste
discipline
se non tutte una sceglietene una
studiate laccati te l'ha imparata i nomi
dei pionieri leggete nelle pubblicazioni
parlatene con gli amici sostenere la
ricerca come potete da queste discipline
e dalle loro intersezioni che
deriveranno gli indizi più precisi sul
momento esatto della singolarità e
guardiamo invece questa lista di
professioni del futuro
mi stupisce quanto sia assente la parola
manager perché il futuro impone verbi
come architettare quantizzare
decentralizzare conversare enfatizzare
perché perché si disegneranno mondi
immersivi si ingegnerizza il tocco si
proteggono dati si allena la la
compassione
ok se vi sembra strana questa lista di
professioni pensate anche che nell'epoca
delle delle rockstar nessuno avrebbe mai
immaginato che 60.000 le vere rockstar
sarebbero stati gli imprenditori del
tech e i programmatori e inevitabile
quindi che certi mestieri non solo
quelli della rockstar possano scomparire
o diventare di nicchia come questi qui a
favore di lavori non ripetitivi
relazionali creativi ma se non altro
perché scompariranno molti oggetti d'uso
comune ai quali siamo abituati
le chiavi
il telecomando il portafoglio e
francobollo nessun computer mai più ci
farà quella domanda odiosa hai
dimenticato la password cioè laughter
hanno negli occhi etica e competenza
sono fondamentali soprattutto se
pensiamo ai nuovi esperimenti di vita
civile
da bravi animali politici quali siamo
già vediamo questi primi esperimenti
insiste dinghy institut che è una think
thank di ingegneri nautici biologi
marini attivisti ambientalisti medici
artisti sta progettando un ecosistema di
nano nazioni galleggianti è un
esperimento condotto da peter thiel e
dal figlio del premio nobel friedman
dall'impronta fortemente libertaria per
testare nuove forme di forme di vita
civile in acque internazionali a
politiche ed esentasse
oppure mio la futura zona franca sul mar
rosso voluta dal principe saudita
mohammed bin salman quindi immaginate la
classica città del futuro grattacieli
big data e ai e droni ovunque wifi
libero per tutti è questa
questo esperimento proviene dal primo
paese che ha garantito un diritto di
cittadinanza per la prima volta nella
storia ad un androide la scenografia di
blade runner la iniziamo quindi a
intravedere anche se a macchia di
leopardo e quello che dice la tech e
vangelis sage francia è che lo sviluppo
di queste nuove competenze di questi
nuovi spazi di vita di queste tecnologie
debbano essere guidati dalle emozioni ed
è curioso pensare al fatto che
l'amigdala la pietra il primo strumento
tecnologico dell'uomo porti allo stesso
nome di quella parte del cervello umano
che ha il compito di gestire le emozioni
quelle emozioni che ci hanno consentito
di trasformarci devolvere progetti
razionali come dicono gli scienziati
dell'evoluzione non dobbiamo fare
l'errore quando parliamo di tecnologia
di
considerare solo l'aspetto tecnico
fisico no il microchip
il circuito questa tecnologia sempre blu
grigia fredda non dobbiamo mai separare
la tecnologia da quello che è il
potenziale di realizzazione della vita
umana che porta con sé cosa sarebbe
stato van gogh
la tecnologia della pittura o bethoven
senza la tecnologia del pianoforte
voglino sauri senza il telescopio anti
meteorite si stima che nel 2005 ci
saranno tre miliardi di persone connesse
in più alla digital economy
grazie alla progressiva riduzione del
digital divide quindi tre miliardi di
persone pronte ad esprimere il proprio
potenziale è un potenziale enorme e non
vedo l'ora di vederlo grazie
[Musica]